[Music]
kathleen stock has faced harassment and
bullying for saying gender is not more
important than biological sex
particularly she said when it comes to
law and policy
is free speech under threat on our
campuses and if so what should be done
i'm joined now by matthew goodwin from
the university of kent and rob ford from
the university of manchester
thanks for joining us both
to start is that something kathleen
stock should have said matt let's come
to you first
yes i think she should be able to
express
her views based on her research i think
uh ultimately
uh one of the reasons why our
universities are world leading
universities um is because of the fact
that we have academics with different
views who can come together and exchange
those views robustly and i also think
given
the wider polarization that we are
experiencing in western democracies it's
more important i think today than ever
to ensure that our students are being
exposed to the very real views and
values that they're going to experience
when they leave university out there in
the real world so i think kathleen has
every right to express her view on
campus
rob
yeah
same same view basically
i mean i i
do not think any academics should be
prevented from saying things that are
perfectly legal within the framework of
law that we have i think there are cases
that are more difficult where one has to
balance
academic free expression with for
example equalities legislation prevent
legislation and so on but the case that
you gave is is not one of those so it's
straightforward she should be able to
say it she shouldn't be facing
intimidation for wanting to say it and
the
notion that this is something that
should not be said is in a liberal one
and wrong
and do you think sussex union has had
the right response here we know that
there is a push
by the union to ultimately call for a
full investigation into transphobia
uh i mean we've got to separate out the
response of the university and the union
because obviously different things
i mean the university's response was to
put its vice chancellor up on the today
program to defend kathleen stocks i
believe the word he used was untrammeled
rights free speech
that strikes me as the right response to
what was a campaign an anonymous
campaign of intimidation on campus he
was standing up for his employee and
their rights
the union's response was rather
disappointing uh i think it would have
been nice for a union which is supposed
to be about defending the rights of
employees to have made clearer
and stronger statement of defense they
did however say that intimidation is
wrong
and they did also raise the point which
hasn't featured much incidentally a
discussion of this incident
that
the details personal details of local
union members at sussex who had raised
these objections were themselves posted
on the internet by various individuals
thereby encouraging further campaigns of
intimidation and frankly i think the
union is right to raise the fact that
that is also not a legitimate way to
conduct this debate
matthew what do you think are we seeing
a wider issue uh when it comes to
academics and um
wariness now about speaking out on
certain issues
i think we are i think in some way
kathleen was um
quite lucky in having a supportive vice
chancellor at least a vice chancellor
who was willing to
to go out there and make make the case
uh in defense of academic freedom that
has not been the case at other
institutions i
would note that the spectator among
others has pointed to the legacy of
stephen tupe at cambridge who would be a
prime example of a vice chancellor who
at least in my view fundamentally failed
to
protect and promote academic freedom and
we've had a number of other cases
in the uk
where vice chancellors have not
proactively
stepped into uh these debates when they
could have actually uh done so and and
and could have could have dampened them
down i'm thinking about the treatment in
particular of neil thin at the
university of uh edinburgh uh who uh was
was sort of hauled through a very long
and messy and public disciplinary
process underlining the key point in
these cases which is that
the
process is the punishment for academics
so your reputation is essentially
shredded
while the university
uh sort of uh bows to to these mobs um i
think uh david runsman at cambridge made
this point very well yesterday in in the
you know even talking politics as sort
of another podcast feels unable to go
near issues uh such as uh gender and uh
uh trans issues because of the fear of
the consequences so we're not even
talking about a small minority uh
pointing to this issue anymore we're
talking about you know uh some of the
most prominent academics in the country
uh both on the left and the right to who
i think are saying you know against the
backdrop of the kathleen stott case it's
no longer credible to say that we do not
have an issue
with academic freedom in the united
kingdom and i think um that is a very uh
depressing place to be um and it reminds
us that we need to do something about it
uh if we're going to be able to move
forward
do you agree with that rob that we now
do have a widespread issue when it comes
to freedom of speech on campuses
i think i would object to the word
widespread um i mean i agree with much
of what matthew says
i think that we are seeing a number of
actors in the debate over the over
gender transgender gender critical who
are behaving in a way that's deeply a
liberal
i think there are examples of university
administrations
failing to provide a sufficiently robust
defense to their members in that area
but i think what
all of that omits is that universities
have more than one set of
responsibilities that they have to speak
to
they do also have to respect equality's
legislation now matthew mentions the
process is the punishment well yes and
that is a problem and sometimes
processes are far too long but to take
another case that has recently happened
this year which isn't on the gender
issue but on the issue of views about
israel
david miller at the university of
bristol lost his job he faced a very
long process it is still to this day not
clear on what grounds he was dismissed
now i would emphasize that in my view
david miller's views were fundamentally
unacceptable because they involved
threatening
disclosing the details of and
threatening and stigmatizing and
stereotyping individual name students at
his campus
but the university has to sort out the
different and conflicting
responsibilities it faces when you have
a situation on the one hand of
protecting the rights of academics to
speak freely and on the other hand
respecting
equality's legislation
with regards to protected
characteristics which would include
gender which would include ethnicity
which would include trans status
that is not necessarily a simple or easy
matter to sort out that does sometimes
require lengthy procedures which may
indeed include a need to remain silent
within a polarized public sphere in
order not to prejudice the case as it
goes through
so while i agree there clearly are
issues with illiberalism on some issues
and and
that illiberalism stretches well beyond
the university campus
it is also the case
that to think of this as an issue
solely in terms of free speech
is to miss the most important source of
tension and conflict within this issue
matthew
well i mean just to go back to your
question i mean i think the
the evidence
on
um
the problem that we have with academic
freedom today uh just before we go into
specific cases
is pretty overwhelming uh about two or
three years ago when a few colleagues
and i
started to race this issue and started
to form a working group on this issue
the
i think it's fair to say
there was a very loud view you might
even say dominant view that this was
being exaggerated that this was being
um
uh perhaps used for political purposes
that essentially it didn't really
exist as an issue and we saw a number of
prominent academics essentially
make that case there was a strong
rebuttal to
some of the arguments that were made
through
various policy reports among a large
number of academics suggesting that this
was
being exaggerated or that we couldn't
possibly make
conclusions uh about threats to academic
freedom based on
what those reports were showing i think
fast forward to today katie and we now
have so much evidence so much research
that i'm glad to see now today actually
against the backdrop of kathleen's case
that everybody now agrees uh with the
exception of one or two radicals who
continue to argue that this is being
made up individuals such as jonathan
porters and others
i think there's a broad consensus on the
left and the right that we have an issue
and recent studies at king's even the
ucu zone survey
shows that one in three academics are
now self-censoring their views on campus
because they fear negative consequences
um they fear what will happen if they do
in in uh air their their real views
which david ransomen i think expressed
very eloquently yesterday on politics
live so we do have an issue and i would
also add that as the government's higher
education and academic freedom bills
passing through parliament which i know
will come on to discuss
i was quite struck by
the testimony from the chief executive
of the office for students who uh also
uh agreed that uh what she was seeing
coming through
um her office on a regular basis pointed
clearly to the need uh for us to take uh
some action on these issues so i i'm i'm
less of the view i i don't share rob's
um
uh
view uh uh about um
uh about the equalities legislation i
think on some of these cases you think
that universities should ignore
equality's legislation no i didn't no i
didn't say that at all that was what i
was saying they have a responsibility so
i i just it's important i can finish if
i just finish the point just if i can
finish the point there are there are
cases such as um kathleen stock's cases
uh neil thin's uh case noah carl's
case i think in some respects how jordan
peterson was treated
at cambridge
among others where actually i think vice
chancellors
senior members of the university
actually have a moral obligation
to make the symbolic and substantive
point
that academic freedom is the primary
goal within
higher education and they can do that in
some cases independently of particular
cases i was quite quite struck by adam
tickle's
response at sussex you know and i
thought it was a very good response
unfortunately he's now stepping down as
vice chancellor and we don't know what
the new vice chancellor is going to say
about this case
but i do think we have a moral
obligation as academics and as leaders
of universities to make the case that
actually the principle the fundamental
principle of academic freedom is one
that we should protect and promote and
the reason the government has not has
decided to take action in this area is
because it's concluded
and i think rightly that universities
have become so ideologically skewed that
they can no longer be relied upon to
promote
that academic freedom
and i think that's a fundamental problem
and just finally
i wanted to ask you both about really
who carries responsibility when it comes
to tackling some of the problems that
you both agree there is a problem
there's obviously a disagreement as to
the exact scale uh response and
perhaps a start begin matthew and then
bring in rob for the final word
you mentioned the government's um you
know free speech bill was doing there
and i just wondered do you think this is
something which is the government can
fix or ultimately is it are there limits
to what the government can really say on
this
so i think this is
um
it's a fascinating case it's a
fascinating case for global reasons as
well the uk is essentially becoming one
of the first
countries to to take such positive
action as in
proactive action on academic freedom the
canadians are watching us very closely
uh politicians in quebec and france are
watching this legislation very closely
um my view used to be i i think i'm
writing saying similar to rob's but i'll
let him speak for himself i used to feel
incredibly uncomfortable about the idea
of government intervening in the higher
education space and
so you know i i've not come at this from
the view that this was my my starting
position but as i've gone through the
last decade in in higher education and
especially the five years since the vote
for brexit
and seeing the treatment of gender
critical scholars
friends in history
psychology even mathematics who have
been bullied harassed intimidated
in some cases sacked or
disinvited
i've come to the conclusion that our
universities are so ideologically skewed
have become monocultures in some cases
that they are unable to be relied upon
to protect and promote academic freedom
and we have lots of research that shows
this when you have very homogenous
institutions they tend to become more
radical over time cass unsteam and
others have shown this and i think
unfortunately that is what's happened in
our universities and this relates also
to issues around china as well which i
know that the spectator has covered uh
as well in some detail so so my sort of
reluctant conclusion and reason for
supporting the bill
is that i think we need culture change
within our universities
and the higher education academic
freedom bill by appointing an external
director of academic freedom who will
essentially provide oversight of issues
around academic freedom take the
kathleen stock case let's imagine for a
second the vc wasn't supportive of
catholic let's imagine for a second that
the ucu as it as it as it was in this
case was not supportive
of kathleen stop where where can she go
apart from walk onto campus and be
bullied and harass now she could bring a
private case she could perhaps um you
know contact lawyers for herself and so
forth um but it becomes that much harder
so so the expectation the hope with this
legislation
is that it will begin to produce culture
changing universities because nothing
drives culture changing universities
more
than having things like league tables on
academic freedom uh and the and the
prospect of having negative publicity
for violating academic freedom as sussex
i'm sure would confirm to us uh this
week and that is the goal here it's not
to have a totalitarian authoritarian
kind of imposition in higher education
as some of our critics have tried to
make out the goal is a simple one which
is to provide an external entity that
academics who are being prosecute being
persecuted for their views and beliefs
can turn to uh to to to secure further
support and to have that uh organization
try and bring about wider culture change
rob do you
think the bill is a good idea
um largely no uh not because i disagree
with the idea that you know
there are issues here
that need
greater attention as i think has become
clear from the conversation we both
agree that particularly in some of the
most contentious areas right now that's
true i just think that if the problem
is a cultural one and i actually agree
that it is a cultural one um and it
stretches beyond campus
that you can't just wave a magic wand
with legislation written on it and you
can't just wave a magic wand with
regulator on it and expect that to solve
the problem and i'll give a few reasons
why i think that that's the case first
of all
the example that matthew gives is not
one that is actually excellent to my
knowledge in any individual case i don't
know of any university academic in
britain
who has
lost their job due to lawful speech
there have been cases that have been
where they have faced harassment and
bullying and so forth it is not clear to
me
what the external regulator would
actually be able to do to change that
situation now that in itself is of
course very sad but it then raises the
question well what's the external
regulator for even in the david miller
case
and miller has lost his job and we still
don't know why
um
[Music]
the university was clear in its
statement that he has not lost his job
because of lawfully expressing his views
it emphasized that his views were an
awful expression of free speech if this
regulator is about regulating the lawful
expression of free speech they're not
going to have a lot to do because most
of the cases that cause trouble
are not about that they're about
universities other duties they're about
their safeguarding duties they're about
their equalities legislation duties
coming into conflict in particular cases
with
this statements
and perceived reactions to those
statements of people on campus and so i
i don't think it will work for that
reason number one number two and this i
think is even more important there's a
jurisdictional problem here if you
actually look closely at many of the
people who protest in many of these
cases i'll give you another example the
germain greer case which incidentally in
the research that matt matt cited it was
treated as a case of cancellation even
though the event went ahead as confirmed
by the person who organized it
it took a while to get them to correct
the record on that
in the jermaine greer case the people
who organized the protest were not from
the university they were reported in the
daily mail as having been students of
the university even though the leader of
the protest confirmed he was not a
university student and had never been a
university student and neither were any
other people involved in the protest
we do have a broader problem here with
rather liberal extreme groups who are
willing to engage in intimidation and
disruption and i think that that is a
disgrace in the liberal society that
that is not the way that you go about
making your case however
that problem very often
does not fall within the jurisdiction of
universities universities cannot
sanction people who are not students or
staff on their campus it is difficult
for them to keep people off their campus
and a third problem i'd like to raise is
the problem of perverse incentives let's
say we have this external regulator and
the external regulator says any
university
that puts an event which is then
cancelled due to intimidation will face
sanction
the way many university administrations
which are institutionally risk-averse
will respond to that is to say any event
where there is a risk of cancellation
will just stop it from happening in the
first place if it's never announced if
it's never on the public record then
it's never cancelled
is that a victory for free speech
i would argue no i would argue the
situation where jermaine greer gets to
speak at cardiff university even despite
the protests is the victory for free
speech probably more people attended it
because of the publicity around the
protests and so forth the situation
where the vice chance of cardiff says oh
i don't want the regulator getting
involved in this this seems a bit like a
dodgy issue where we're going to have
trouble and media attention let's just
not put it on that's not a victory for
free speech that's the opposite
and my concern with this legislation is
there's a failure to think through some
of the perverse incentives that it risks
creating
thanks rob and thanks matt
[Music]
you